what all can you do at night
in animal crossing new horizons good
evening people of the internet and
welcome to the night owl the laid-back
let's play series for
animal crossing new horizons as you can
see here it is just
after 11 p.m on monday april 5th
i'm your host retro recontour and if
we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories
they tell i invite you to get
comfortable sit back
relax and enjoy the sights and music of
animal crossing in the evening
feel free to throw this on in the
background while you're working on other
tasks or maybe while you're just winding
down for the night
trying to get some sleep as this is our
first
video in this series i thought it would
be best for me to show you all some of
the activities that
i enjoy in the evening hours of animal
crossing
so i think i'll start by giving you a
brief tour of my island
show you what it looks like in its
current state also to let you know some
areas that i'm
hoping to work on in future installments
of the series
we'll also see if there's anything fun
we can get into as there are some events
that
only take place at night now as i've
been standing here kind of walking
around
hopefully you've been able to take in
some of the sounds
in this spot right here of course
there's the music of the game which
on its own especially in the evening is
just a a nice
relax i mean let's be honest it's always
pretty relaxing
i don't know that there's any hour of
the day where the
animal crossing music isn't relaxing
but i really enjoy the nighttime music
and you can also hear the waterfall
so on the right of the screen to the
left of my character here
and then as i get closer to this fire i
was sitting down here earlier let's go
ahead and sit down again
you just get that soft crackle as well
now one of the things that you can do at
night is you can look for shooting stars
and i love this spot on my island
there's another spot i'll show you here
in a moment that i enjoy looking for
shooting stars
this spot right here as well is also
really really fun to watch shooting
stars from right here
i like it because it's calm it's
peaceful you're not obstructed by
anything so i don't have to worry about
any tree i know there's a tree on the
left but you don't have to worry about
any other trees in your way
you get a nice clear view of the sky
here on the
top level of my island i don't have any
other cliffs in the background here
then of course we've got the campground
area right here for whenever we have a
visitor this is where they stay at the
campsite
and then just some other items that you
might find on a campground to go with
that
overall theme now the sign over here at
the entrance
one of my favorite parts as well
welcoming people in
look at that half moon right there look
at that just just
half of it in shadow there with a nice
crescent moon here on
monday april 5th as we get ready to
head into tuesday april 6th so i'm going
to go ahead and take you guys this way
now i'm going to pick some of these
weeds right here
i haven't been well
i have been slightly neglecting my
island but
in this case right here i haven't been
so much neglecting the island as
some of the weeds have gotten a little
out of control because i want to
actually leave a few of them
because i'm going for kind of a more
rustic look here
considering that this is the campsite
area
got the little bamboo right there with
the water and then here we have
huck's house so the reason that huck's
house is here
is because it it's a log cabin
essentially right
and he's got the telescope here so he
can take in some shooting stars himself
but one of the ideas that i've recently
been pursuing and that we're going to
talk about as i
move throughout my island tonight is
i've been trying to set up
themed areas now i told you the
campground is one spot that i've had for
a while and that's true
however it hasn't always had huck's
house there
usually or used to be i should say it
was just a
stand-alone campground there was
nothing in terms of housing up here all
of my houses
i can actually pull out and show you on
my map here
previously all of the houses were
located in the bottom
right quadrant that kind of bottom right
square over there
of my island and you can see there's
still a majority of them there we got
what six houses over there right now
but two are up here in this campground
area
and then two in the northwest
section of my map you see there in the
top left
and this is an idea that i've seen
online and i really wanted to try it
myself and that's
setting up these themed areas so with
this being an outdoorsy
camp area i wanted to pick homes that
looked like they belong here and so
here's another one
this is actually beau's home right here
happy birthday to bo
by the way all right so instead of
continuing on
down right here i think i'd like to take
you up this way
and we're going to go back past my house
now i didn't talk about my house much
when we first started the video
but here is where my wife lives
this house right here the house in the
middle
is mine and then the house on the far
left over here
is my six-year-old son's so you can see
we kind of
let him do whatever he wants out here
for his section of the yard
but i do need to get this cleaned up
over here i don't like how the
paths are going here at all so in future
videos we'll
have one where we work on terraforming
and overall
layout of the island this will
definitely be something that i want to
fix
just to make this look more balanced
overall because i'm
i'm not liking the way it's looking
right now right here
i originally tried to line this up
perfectly with the front door of my home
and i don't believe i was able to do it
so basically it's lined up
you know right here with the left side
but it was one of those
awkward situations where if i went over
one more space this way
then it would have been lined up with
this one in the middle so there was no
way to get it perfectly in line
with two of these or maybe i was just
botching it but at least to me it didn't
look like you could
so definitely got some stuff to work on
up here with the pathing
i do like the trees though how they're
laid out right here
and how we're at kind of that
northernmost part in the middle
of our island right here we've got some
work to do with the flowers i want to
keep the balance
that i have going right here but
eventually i want to
make this even more unifying in terms of
which flowers are in
which spots then we got the nice
waterfall here
and then this spot is 100 done this is
exactly
how i want this so we've got the tulips
here we've got the trees on either side
and then a little courtyard here of
golden roses
surrounding the fountain here along with
the waterfall
so again going with that overall
relaxing vibe
showing off a little bit i admit i admit
showing off somewhat with all the gold
roses here
and that brings us to number two of
things that you can do
at night in animal crossing is you can
use that time
to water your flowers and also try and
grow flowers
that your you maybe don't have yet
flowers that you're trying to get
and i know the golden rose is a very
popular one
for a lot of people so i'll show you
here in a second where exactly
i grow these originally because this is
not where they grow i move them
here but i have a spot on my island that
is
dedicated to breeding new flowers
whenever i need something now as we
continue over here to the right this is
ultimately
kind of an apple orchard right here a
small apple orchard
this may change at some point but right
now i'm happy with this
the way it is i have yet to see any
layout online for a fruit orchard that i
am
truly happy about i've tried a couple
different things on my island and i'll
i'll show you some of those here as well
let's go ahead and head across the
bridge here and this is going to take
you into the main
town square so on the left here we have
the museum
got the t-rex outside there
and then over here on the right you'll
see the able sister shop
along with nook's cranny which because
we're playing so late
they are not open so i'm going to go
ahead and turn that light out
and then overall here we're just going
for again that relaxing
cozy vibe so got the nice little bench
right there
and then here a little courtyard with a
fountain
in the center
and there's also a little path here
bird bath on either side bird house in
the middle
and then this area over here leads to
a farm area eventually that now this
farm area is not
complete yet i've got a lot of work and
layout that i want to do here a lot of
shifting of things but you can already
see how we're starting to get some
organization here
with the pumpkins and behind that we've
got a
lot of free space this is where my wife
or excuse me my son and i used to live
on a big hill
right here but we terraformed all that
changed that up
moved us to the back of the island to
free up
this space right here this very large
space that you see
in front of me
so i may find some houses that i can put
in that
villager houses that is that i can put
in that area that
fit that overall theme so here's the
main courtyard
let's go ahead and pass through here and
then this area right here
we have the waterfalls on either side
this is an idea i saw online
kind of flanking the entrance
to our museum so that
is pretty much done i don't foresee any
changes there
got the fossils up top there on either
side
and then over here this spot right here
guys this is a very special spot to me
one of my favorite in the entire island
uh because
again just super relaxing but
this plant that you see right here some
of you may be newer to the game
maybe thinking i haven't seen that plant
before some of you who have been playing
the game for a while may be
working toward that plant if you don't
know what it is it is the
lily of the valley and it only grows on
your island when you hit
five stars and it will continue to grow
in random spots on your island as long
as you're five stars
so keep that in mind but what's so
special about this spot to me is this
one
right here in the middle was the
very first lily of the valley that ever
grew
on my island and i will always keep it
in that spot
now this isn't the spot that it grew you
can move them some people
uh in fact i at first when i grew one i
was like okay wait can i move this or is
it going to
destroy it or something no you can you
can totally pick it up as you can any
other flower
using your shovel jeez
i was like wait what is the tool again
yeah using the shovel
you can pick it up and plant it
somewhere else so you can totally do
that
and i moved it here and kind of built
this little garden area around it
which i really really love i love the
vibes this place here
speaking of the shovel though let's move
this one out of the way because that is
not where
i want that and i have more lily of the
valleys that i'll show you here in a bit
another area that took me a really
long time to do but i am very very happy
that i did
and that is creating this rock garden
fellow youtuber really good animal
crossing youtuber mayor
mori that's m a y o r space
m-o-r-i has a great video
showing you how to create your very own
rock garden
now what's great about the rock garden
first of all doesn't that look pretty
cool
doesn't that look pretty cool being able
to have all your islands rocks laid out
in kind of a
a pattern that you decide and set them
up
exactly that way that's what we have
here and
i'll never destroy these rocks and we'll
always keep them in this spot so
part one it looks great part two is
that you never have to go searching
around your island whenever you need
any of the materials of course that come
from rocks
so when you need gold nuggets for
example
which are pretty rare iron nuggets
clay any of that stuff you can just take
care of your rocks for the day
all in one spot right here so this is a
third thing
talking about things we can do at night
in animal crossing
you can set up your island
to make your very own rock garden now i
mentioned that mayor mori video
essentially what it involves is placing
down a whole lot of
mannequins on your island you have to
kind of trick the game into thinking
there's nowhere
else to put these new rocks except for
wait what was that did you hear that
did you guys hear that
that's right folks that's right we just
got
that's our second shooting star there's
a third shooting star
they usually come in waves of five per
minute let's see
three per minute or five per minute so
that was that was three
very quick there's another one
and another one wow would you look at
that our first episode
i promise i i didn't check medio nook
beforehand to see
if we had one tonight but that is that
is awesome
so we just got five shooting stars right
there guys
and what's really special about shooting
stars if you're new to the game and you
don't know what's what's the big deal
right so
you saw me there uh do that little kind
of special thing
i don't know what it looks like on
screen exactly to you but it's it's
wishing upon a star
and you press the a button to do that so
you have to look up you have to position
your camera
in that spot like i did and
then you have to press a whenever you
see the shooting star
and what's so special about shooting
stars is that the next day
so i need to make sure i check tomorrow
along
my beach i will find
an item called star fragments
and these star fragments you may have
seen star fragments already in a recipe
that's actually how i learned about them
first as i saw them in a recipe
i thought what in the world what's
what's a star fragment you know
the only way to get star fragments
unless you're just gifted them from a
friend
is you have to see and wish upon a
shooting star like i did there moments
ago
and then you will find them on the shore
the next day
now a lot of times people just they find
one and then they they leave and they
think that's it
no they will appear in multiple spots if
you if you wish upon
more than one shooting star they will
appear
throughout the day on your shore so make
sure you go all around your island
and check a couple of times to pick up
all the star fragments
that you can find so i'm really glad you
guys got to see that we've talked about
a couple of things already
special activities that you can do at
night and as i was saying there
to create your own rock garden it
essentially involves putting mannequins
that's right you heard me mannequins
putting mannequins
all over your island so there's nowhere
else
for rocks to go so if you didn't know
you can destroy rocks by eating fruit
so you eat a fruit and then you can use
an ax
or the shovel to destroy a rock
and then that rock will reappear in the
coming days
now normally this will appear at random
so if i
went and destroyed one of those rocks
over there tomorrow it could show up
in this spot right here or it could show
up let's see if we got another open spot
here somewhere
couldn't show up in any of these spots
because i've got these hard paths
here we got a balloon right there
first try there we go see we got
cherry blossom wand would you look at
that
folks would you look at that cherry
blossom one let's go ahead and learn
that recipe
awesome i didn't have that one yet
but yeah you put those mannequins up all
across your island
trust me it takes a lot of time
it's very tedious and for the duration
of the
roughly a week to two weeks that you're
going to be doing this because trust me
you won't get it right the first night
you most likely will not get it right
the first night which means you're going
to have a rock
pop up in a spot that you didn't realize
you missed
and then it will show up and you'll have
to destroy that rock and then put a
mannequin there
so it's going to be annoying for a
couple days is you have to run around
and avoid all those mannequins
but once you're done if if that what you
saw
here i'll show you one more time what
you saw with my right
rock garden is something that you
yourself would like to try
then it is well worth it for both
convenience
and just overall visual appeal of the
island
so considering that we have seen
shooting stars that means that
celeste is a possibility so we'll have
to walk around the island and
see if we can find celeste here
and that's another thing that you can do
only at night there are certain
folks in animal crossing that you can
only see in the evening hours celeste
wait what i thought that was her right
there no it's just stella
uh oh wow well thank you
dude hamlet so nice of you to water that
lily of the valley right there
really appreciate that
but yeah now that we saw those shooting
stars i kind of want to take a look
around and see oh now we got a bottle
too
see if we can get another new recipe
here
iron frame yeah i thought i already had
that one
i'll save it give it to my son or my
wife they probably don't have it
but yeah now that we've seen those
shooting stars we know for sure
that there's a chance celeste could be
there so oh
would you look at that folks would you
would you look at that
so yeah we get to visit with celeste
tonight now
on certain days you may see celeste uh
you can see celeste
earlier oh good evening aren't the stars
just exquisite tonight yes
indeed celeste they are hootie toot i
almost forgot i came across a recipe for
an astronomical project in a book
and jotted it down anytime you see
celeste guys make sure you talk to her
because you want to get the special
recipe she always has recipes unless
you've
collected them all
have a splendid rest of the night i know
i shall
all right let's see what we got here
dude all the recipes tonight
aries rocking chair don't think i have
that one
don't think i have that one
all right we gotta take a look right
away don't we we gotta we gotta see what
this looks like
oh my goodness are you serious right
i don't know that i'll make that but
it's pretty cool
and then right here the cherry blossom
wand i have a goal i want to try and
collect all the wands
some of you may have came across that
video i have a video about everything
you need to know about wands
i really want to collect all the wands
now i mentioned earlier in the video
that i would show you another spot where
i love to watch shooting stars
it's the dock right here the dock i love
just
getting out here on the water just
me and the music of the game definitely
no trees
or anything else to obstruct your view
when you're in this spot right here
just a wonderful wonderful spot to wait
for shooting stars and you don't have to
worry about anything at all
obstructing your view it's it's really
nice really nice
when we got look at that another present
back there in the background
all right so we saw the shooting stars
and i got a little bit sidetracked on my
island tour for you guys so you've been
you've been taking it in some though as
we go
so you can see all this over here is
kind of a work in progress i'm
eventually going to move some of these
houses
but i want them to be villagers that i
know
i want to keep around one of them is
diana so this is diana's house here
diana is for sure staying she is
absolutely in my long-term villager
plans
uh her house totally of course fits with
diana style
uh very ritzy very glamorous i think
that i will end up putting her on the
beach
i don't know for sure yet i might just
leave her there because you know it
costs a lot of money
we got plenty of money in this game
though but it costs a little bit and you
have to wait that day
for it to move here or wherever i decide
it may not be
right here in this exact area of the
beach
but i am considering her i just get
beachy vibes from diana
but some of the other homes belong to
villagers that i don't know
will be sticking around beau and huck
along with
cherry and let's see who's the other one
octavian
i have them moved in places that i know
they're going to stick around they're
long-term villagers that i hope to keep
around for a while
so let me just show you the entrance so
if you ever were to visit my island and
you
you hop off the plane exit the airport
here
you're going to be met with lily of the
valley plants right away
a little bit of a flex yeah i guess
i guess you caught me a little little
bit of a flex there
showing off the lily of the valley
plants right when you walk in
got the stone walls here on either side
and then i had this here pointing
just to let people know hey this is kind
of the residential area there's going to
be
houses this way that may eventually
have to change because of we'll see how
many houses i end up moving
i may keep some here
but ultimately i want the houses to be
in kind of a themed area so we have to
figure out what theme we would want to
go with
if we're going to keep some kind of here
in this spot
then if you head this way you guys
already saw the beach there we talked
about the zen garden
but one thing we didn't talk about that
i teased earlier
another thing you can work on at night
is breeding
new flowers watering flowers making sure
you water them
if you're trying to get new colors
and this spot right over here you guys
may have noticed it earlier this spot
right here is where i
shoot for my gold roses
so i'll pull up my golden watering can
that is the only way to get a golden
rose guys is if you have
a black rose which you can get from
a red rose and then you have to water
the black
roses with the golden watering can for a
chance so it's not a guarantee a lot of
people think once they get the golden
watering can and
water black rose that it's a guarantee
but that that is not the case
you just get a chance you can see like
this spot right here
this is a new one growing this is a new
one growing because i watered those
around it
in the hopes that it would be a golden
rose
now the range i found on the watering
can is a little interesting
it actually extends out a little bit
further than you think
like see that right there actually ended
up getting both
this one here
and then also this one down here
and you know that because of the little
shiny glint
that you see as you wait here
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and i
don't have to get all these because i've
got plenty of golden roses already but
i'd like to have a couple more
all right so i think that's good for now
now this area up here
i'm not sure if this will change or if
i'll keep this
i know for sure i want to clean up the
flowers this is just
you know the flowers are out of control
right now honestly i really just want
one kind of one long column here of
flowers on this side
with the dirt path underneath
and then same thing over here one long
column of flowers on that side as well
that's what i'm ultimately why i was
about to say working toward
no i had it but then all the other
flowers that you know grow
off of the others are here and i just
need to go through and
and i think my problem is when i pick
them up i hate just
selling flowers because they're not
worth very much and having more flowers
on your island helps you
keep your star rating up so i kind of
want to keep the flowers around for star
rating purposes but
i need a better spot for them so if you
guys have any ideas by the way on how i
can improve my island i'd love to hear
from you guys so let me know down in the
comments below what you think
this area right here
so leads over to this so we were just
over here
in my little lily of the valley garden
then when you head
into this spot right here you are now
entering
my theme park the retro land
theme park which has underwent a lot of
changes lately
i mentioned the theme areas and how i'm
trying to do that so
octavian how octavian's house
octavian house i guess we could just
call it octavian house right that'd be
kind of cool
octavian house so octavian lives here
and i thought this went very well with
the fencing that i have right here
and then cherry is back here as well
cherry just strikes me as somebody who
would love to live in a theme park
so we've got cherry and octavian both
here and then
this kind of main center plaza
for the theme park we've got food in the
background got plenty of seating
see the problem was guys i i had this
huge theme park up here
there's a video on youtube of me
building a theme park it started out it
was terrible
my first building a theme park video
it's one of the first videos i had on
youtube that started to take off but
a few months into it i'm like oh my
goodness this is terrible my
my my theme park was actually pretty bad
so i made another one but not nearly as
many people were interested in that
video
but i totally revamped it and i had this
huge theme park all of this
everything over here was part of the
theme park everything down here
was part of the theme park all all of
this stuff was theme park related
and what i noticed was that no one ever
came here none of my villagers i never
saw them hanging out
in the theme park and it kind of to me
at least defeated the whole purpose
of having a theme park like what's the
point if none of the villagers are going
to be in there and use it
and so i decided you know what let's set
up these themed areas we'll have some
folks
live in the theme park area and sure
enough
the very next day after i moved octavian
here
i found him sitting over here at this
table
i found him just relaxing here and i was
like yes that
that is what i was going for so a lot of
this
is has been here for a while and will
stay here
but then as we start to get over here to
the right side this is all
a work in progress once again so you see
we've got
kind of some flowers out of control
right here i've stored these items here
for now because i want this to be a
pirate themed area a pirate themed
area right here is where jolly red
comes to visit whenever red shows up
this is where he is
right here and so i don't know
he's a guy who comes in on a boat and he
sells stolen goods i just get some
pirate vibes
from jolly red so i i felt pirates
and that theme would suit him well so
i'm kind of tossing these items here for
now
and eventually i have no idea what it's
going to look like but eventually i want
this all to be very
pirate themed this spot right here as we
head on down though i don't really know
what i'm going to do with this yet
so again send those ideas in if you have
them
all right so one more thing i'll show
you guys here
and i mentioned other people that you
can see at night on your island special
visitors
uh one is wisp the ghost
i realize some people only play the game
in the day
and don't play at night so you may have
never had a chance
to run into wisp the ghost now i don't
want to totally ruin him for you i might
make a whole separate video on wisp
but he only comes out after 10 pm and is
definitely worth
talking to him because he will always
give you something in return if you uh
do a little task for him so wisp is
pretty funny he he always reacts the
same way
but you'll just find him kind of
floating around and then you just walk
right up and talk to him so
this warp pipe here by the way connects
to the other side of my island
so we'll just go ahead and hop in i'll
show you guys real quick
and there we go out on the other side so
a nice way to quickly traverse
to another spot on your island now we
already talked about celeste we already
talked about breeding flowers
so just to kind of wrap up here and
give you guys one more thing that you
can do in the evening hours of animal
crossing
and that is catch special bugs and fish
i highly recommend checking out the
animal crossing wiki
the animal crossing wiki because they
will tell you which
bugs and fish are available at different
times of the year
and at different times of the day let's
see what we get right here
i think you guys already know i think
i think most people probably saw that
one coming
no surprise we get a sea bass right
there but yeah certain fish and certain
bugs
do only come out late at night
so make sure you're checking that list
over on the animal crossing wiki and if
you aren't familiar with it i'll include
a link down in the description don't
worry
but it is a great resource if you're
working toward
getting the golden fishing rod and you
want to get all the fish in the game
or you want to catch all the bugs in the
game complete your museum
it's a really helpful tool and guys i
think that is going to wrap us up
for today or should i say for this
evening
thank you all so much for being with me
for this journey of our first episode in
this new let's play series
the night owl this has been your host
retrorecontour
signing off